[Musique]
oui
bonjour merci de nous rejoindre sur tv
soixante dix huit pour cette édition un
peu particulière due à 7,8 politique
nous sommes dans les locaux de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines l'élection du président vient
de sites terminé bonjour jean michel
fourgous
bonjour vous êtes donc officiellement le
nouveau président de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines 38 voix se
sont reportés sur votre candidature
25 sur celle de bertrand guillon le
maire de magny les hameaux qui est lui
était aussi candidat et il ya eu dix
bulletins blancs et un bulletin nul
voilà pour le résultat complet votre
sentiment déjà sur ce vote
mais goûter le principal c'est de gagner
et de ensuite deux assemblées
sur les gens qui ont pas tout de suite
voté pour vous c'est ce que génère des
grandes élections comme là c'est une
élection d'un d'un symbole important
france l'agglomération de saint quentin
monte quand même en gamme avec la
qualité et des entreprises et
laboratoires des universités des
chercheurs et des événements
aujourd'hui connotation mondiale que
vous connaissez donc il s'agit de
rassembler après après tout le monde
autour de ses grands projets je pense
que cette agglomération a beaucoup de
chance et je salue mes prédécesseurs
c'est pas moi qui ai fait tout cela et
moi maintenant d'apporter une valeur
ajoutée ainsi vous faire élire président
il faut être capable d'apporter une
valeur ajoutée à l'ensemble de ses
qualités de ses projets de ses ses
savoir faire qu'il y a donc voilà
beaucoup de beaucoup d'ambitions pour
avec cette équipe
bien sûr qui est que l'on va de plus en
plus rassemblée vous parliez du travail
de vos prédécesseurs on va rappeler que
l'élection était provoquée par le départ
de michel laugier sa démission puisqu'il
a été élu sénateur lors du dernier
scrutin
vous allez vous inscrire dans la
continuité de ce qui a été fait par
michel laugier m'écouter effectivement
eu des sénatoriales et ont été très
surpris d'ailleurs c'était pas évident
que cinq sénateurs soit et bus étaient
cinquièmes sur le marché donc c'est une
belle performance donc effectivement ça
nous a ayant qu'il a fallu bien sûr des
élections très rapidement derrière et
que la loi du cumul
voilà donc
alors j'ai travaillé chez logic cgt son
premier vp aussi evp beaucoup sur la
partie économique notamment donc on a
beaucoup travaillé ensemble et on a déjà
réalisé un certain nombre
d'améliorations d'évolution qui sont
bonnes pour l'économie bien sûr hélas
que l'économie il faut quand même mais
sur assurer les moyens de chaque commune
puisque aujourd'hui à l'agglomération et
partagent la gestion de chaque commune
et donc il faut que les moyens soient là
pour lancer des bons investissements
pour faire de la qualité pour répondre à
toutes les demandes croissantes de nos
administrés là il faut bien sûr assuré
que la caisse est bien là qu'elle est
que les comptes sont équilibrés que même
en baisse la dette vous le savez on a en
a b c
on n'a pas augmenté les impôts on a
baissé la dette et en augmenter même la
qualité de service donc tout cela dans
des conditions difficiles où c'est la
chute des notations enfin est ce qu'au
niveau national voilà donc pour
l'instant tout cela est bien parti et
les agences de notation ou le savent et
dont la première mondiale qui est ce à
dire une course nous a remonté même donc
tout cela est d'un est plutôt bon signe
pour enchaîner sur revient sur tous les
grands projets qu'on doit financer
vous parliez aussi d'une volonté aussi
de rassembler là on peut parler de cette
main tendue aux communes de gauche
notamment puisque vous avez proposé des
vice présidences et puis au sein de la
majorité aussi à la voix de joséphine
coleman berger qui est aujourd'hui la
première vice présidente elle a été
désignée également ce soir et qui
appelait aussi à ce rassemblement à
cette sérénité
vous lui répondez quoi directement ce
soir m'a d'abord je la fais il y en fin
de première vice présidente
donc c'est une preuve de confiance la
même si on a une primaire donc
effectivement également candidat s'il
avait remporté ses la vie démocratique
et c'est bien que tout le monde est
respectée
les règles démocratiques donc c'est
plutôt bon signe pour l'avenir et pour
ce grand rassemblement qu'on souhaite
maintenant avec bien sûr nos collègues
de gauche précise que vous leur avez
proposées seront
bien sûr décider avec leurs contenus
dans les semaines qui viennent puisqu'il
faudrait que ce soit réglé avant
prochain comité que tout soit qu'on
puisse tous partir dans le même sens
voilà donc c'est la première tâche qui
m'incombe dans le dans les quatre
semaines à venir
une fois passée cette gestion cette mise
en place des vice-présidences la
priorité pour saint quentin en yvelines
il ya une mobilisation aussi sur la
ligne 18 qui est importante pour
l'avenir aussi économique du territoire
on a des atouts indiscutables saint
quentin on est deux épines dans le pied
vous venez de le dire 5,18 bon donc il
va faire une mobilisation générale tous
les élus bien sûr et puis la chute des
dotations qui bien entendu affaiblit nos
communes et puis même mais même l'agglo
donc en dehors de ces deux épines
il ya des atouts considérables on a on
est aujourd'hui quand même une des
plates formes entrepreneuriales un peu
modèle en france donc il s'agit de la
conforter aussi bien pour les jeunes
chefs d'entreprise que des entreprises
déjà installées que pour les grands
groupes qui sont présents également
développé est une plate forme
d'exemplarité aussi au niveau
universitaire il faut qu' on est un
modèle éducatif de l'enseignement
supérieur qui soit qui nous place dans
le fameux classement de shanghai dans le
top 20 et on est en train d'organiser
bien sûr ces choses pour que notre
université de saint quentin intègre tout
cela est que les gens qui viendront
demain à saint quentin ou même
aujourd'hui jeunes puissent avoir une
des belles johnny une la plus belle
université française la transformation
numérique qui va se faire dans tout le
temps tout laquelle elle à la vie des
citoyens
il faut que saint-quentin soi même au
niveau sportif également est évident que
les grands événements stimule la passion
du sport des enfants des adultes
donc il faut que là dessus on soit dans
l'exemplarité donc voilà vous avez tous
les paramètres vous allez les plus
belles boîtes peuvent être entreprises
les plus beaux laboratoire vous serez
seulement une des meilleures universités
en france demain
avec tout cela avec des événements
sportifs qui donne une lisibilité
internationale menant à saint quentin
vous êtes à 20 me 30 minutes de paris
or encombrement de la public a pu tel du
monde enfin si avec tout ça on arrive à
créer une synergie et à donner envie aux
gens de s'impliquer encore plus de se
rassembler de de comprendre le monde de
demain de se préparer à le changer parce
que c'est ça la recherche
écoutez moi je pense qu'on peut devenir
la la la plate forme d'exemplarité de
l'innovation française le modèle de
l'innovation france français avec
toujours en plus cela la silicon valley
à la française qui se crée avec paris
c'est clair on est au coeur on est le
coeur économique de paris saclay donc
avec tout ça honnêtement il faudrait
être mauvais pour ne pas réussir à être
dans l'exemplarité nationale a beaucoup
d'atouts pour saint quentin
il ya beaucoup dette ou même votre
télévision de mal elle grandira
certainement là vous avez vous avez tous
les équipements sportifs qui sont assez
prestigieux à saint quentin vous avez un
niveau culturel aussi un grand projet
culturel vous verrez c'est un grand
projet sportif et surtout
l'accompagnement des entreprises
l'accueil d'entreprises qui assure quand
même de train de vie bien sûr de les
bichonner les aimer et de lettres bien
montrer qu'on est on est aussi la ville
qui bichonne alors c'est beaucoup
d'entreprises high-tech bien sûr même si
demain vous aurez une autre façon de
travailler et vous aurez donc on va
essayer d'être un peu en modèle dans
toutes ces révolutions l'école
l'éducation l'université le monde du
travail la santé aussi on pas l'oublier
alors alors mais ça ça dépend des moyens
il faut d'abord assurer les moyens et
après on redéploie sur tous ces grands
enjeux
avec tous les toute la chance que nous
avons d'avoir cette agglomération qui
est déjà quand même extrêmement équipe
et qu un niveau déjà d'engagement dans
l'innovation qui est assez
extraordinaire dont il fallait il suffit
de pousser un peu de pousser les lignes
mais comptez sur moi tu sais je sais
faire
voilà ce que je peux vous dire merci
beaucoup jean michel fourgous nouveau
président donc de saint quentin en
yvelines
[Musique]
la suite du 7-8 politique toujours
consacré à cette nouvelle élection de la
nouvelle présidence de l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines bonjour à
joséphine que le mas berger bonsoir même
parce que le conseil d'agglomération
vient de se terminer conseil qui a été
tardif il a fallu réattribuer tous les
postes il ya ces votes qui se sont
déroulés vous avez pris la parole au
début du conseil pour appeler à une une
présidence sereine une présidence
apaisée c'est fédératrice on va dire ces
deux buts c'est l'objectif de votre
déclaration au début du conseil oui
c'est tout à fait ça c'est à dire que on
avait déjà senti que il y avait des
ouvertures qui était possible et il me
semble aujourd'hui que on est dans cette
dynamique là donc ça ça me conforte
véritablement sur cette nouvelle
gouvernance et j'ai voulu prendre la
parole pour réaffirmer mon engagement
puisque vous savez je m'occupe du projet
de territoire et ce projet de territoire
est justement un socle fédérateur donc
c'était pour rappeler que c'était
important que nous allions dans ce sens
si vous aviez été candidat de ce lors de
la primaire qui avait organisé à droite
face à jean-michel fourgous qui lui est
donc l'a emporté aujourd'hui est devenu
le nouveau président aujourd'hui vous
récupérez la première vice-présidence
j'imagine que vous allez aussi vouloir
vous faire entendre et entendre aussi
votre voix au sein de cette
agglomération comme comme avant rien de
plus ni de moi je pense que
effectivement d'avoir participé aux
primaires et bien ça nous a donné une
orientation et un choix une décision qui
est une décision tout à fait
démocratique
voilà je suis aujourd'hui première
vice-présidente comme je l'étais
précédemment avec un autre président il
n'y a pas de souci on va travailler
ensemble on va essayer de faire au mieux
pour fédérer et puis essayer de faire je
dirais de notre de notre agglomération
une vraie ambition de territoire ce soit
il ya des vice présidences qui ont été
proposées pour les communes de gauche
les quatre communes de gauche de saint
quentin en yvelines les élus ne se sont
pas encore prononcés vous souhaitez
véritablement qu'ils intègrent les
vice-présidences qu'il récupère des
postes qu'ils soient aussi très présent
c'est une
pour moi c'est quelque chose
d'indispensable nous nous sommes
aujourd'hui je dirais douze communes
avec douze villes et des habitants il me
semble tout à fait légitime qu'ils
puissent entrer en tout cas dans une
gouvernance
après vous avez pu entendre le président
il a déjà évoqué le sujet en disant
qu'ils avaient cette ouverture de quatre
présidences je pense que les discussions
vont rentrer et ça me semble aujourd'hui
important je l' ai toujours dit ça a
toujours été une demande de ma part mais
une demande aussi d'autres d'autres élus
parce que ça nous semble tout à fait
légitime
donc on va y arriver je suis très
optimiste
je crois que jean michel fourgous a
véritablement envie d'avoir cette
ouverture je pense qu'on va rapidement
faire des réunions et entendre aussi les
maires de gauche
aujourd'hui le mot d'ordre c'est aussi
la stabilité il ya eu beaucoup de
changements des changements d au sein de
l'agglomération avec des élections là le
départ de michel laugier ya eu
l'ouverture de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
puisque plaisir aussi donc à rejoindre
la communauté d'agglomération
aujourd'hui il faut cette stabilité pour
aussi à se faire entendre même au niveau
national parce qu'il ya des dossiers
importants je pense à la ligne 18 par
exemple où les exerçons déjà mobilisés
oui on était d'ailleurs présent à
guyancourt pour effectivement défendent
cette union 18 et puis on a des enjeux
très importants - j'évoquais justement
dans mon discours ce fameux projet de la
région métropole on va en faire partie
on veut en faire partie et on a tout à
fait tout toutes les possibilités et
puis toutes les qualités pour pouvoir
entrer dans cette dynamique là donc ça
me semble je dirais une une vraie
démarche positive et on on est en est je
dirais dans une ambition non seulement
de territoire au niveau de 50 ha mais
une ambition aussi nationale je crois
qu'on a notre place à jouer
véritablement la priorité aujourd'hui
pour saint-quentin justement sur le
mandat plusieurs fois vous avez entendu
le mot de projet de territoire je crois
que c'est pas anodin ça veut dire que
voilà on est rentré dans cette démarche
le projet territoire et notre socle mais
c'est aussi notre feuille de route et je
crois que on est tout à fait aujourd'hui
à même de mettre en application cette
feuille de route et ce projet de
territoire
donc l'enjeu est bien c'est déjà ça
c'est à dire de voir comment dans les 15
20 ans on va pouvoir émerger de tout de
tout s'est tu
cette compétence que nous avons eues par
rapport à ce projet de territoire les
grandes lignes puisque vous avez
travaillé dessus ont peut-être en
profiter
en tout cas ce qu'on peut vous dire sans
parler des grandes lignes parce que ça
pourrait être un peu technocratique pour
le moment mais en tout cas c'est de dire
qu'on a compris que les habitants parce
que ce qui est fondamental pour nous
c'est l'humain et les habitants ont
besoin aujourd'hui de se sentir
je dirais de prendre de prendre une
appropriation du territoire on a du
travail sur le territoire mais il faut
encore le développer le développement
économique est quelque chose de
fondamental mais aussi on s'est rendu
compte que les personnes ne restez pas
forcément c'est à dire les étudiants ou
les personnes qui travaillent il faut
véritablement créer des lieux de vie
c'est fondamental site un des axes
premier et puis on a aussi aujourd'hui
des enjeux qui sont au niveau
bien sûr des start up et de toutes les
nouveautés de l'innovation quelque chose
à faire véritablement là dedans puis on
à saclay et puis on a je dirai tout
c'est proximité de territoire et puis je
crois que les territoires vont bouger
donc il faut qu'on soit prêt pour ça non
seulement pour expliquer ce qu'est notre
projet de territoire et pourquoi on
accepte bien sûr et on voudrait que
peut-être il ya des agrandissements et
puis aussi pour que nous existions il
conçoit pas enfermer la ligne 18 est
pour nous un vrai enjeu d'ouverture au
reste
l'élargissement de l'agglomération à
d'autres communes c'est donc d'actualité
plus tôt c'est dans l'actualité aurait
en réfection tout cas c'est pas moi qui
en ait l'autorité mais on commence à
évoquer
donc je crois qu'effectivement il ya des
choses qui risquent de bouger dans les
années qui viennent
merci beaucoup je vous en prie première
vice-présidente de saint quentin en
yvelines pour cette nouvelle mandature
[Musique]
nouvelle séquence de ce set 8 politique
avec othman d'un trou à présent bonjour
bonjour si nous avoir rejoint donc 7,8
ce politique consacrée à cette élection
du président de l'agglomération et du
nouveau bureau nouvelle organisation et
vous aviez souhaité pendant justement
c'est cette période où michel logis
avait annoncé son départ qu'il y ait une
primaire d'organiser cette primaire a eu
lieu jean michel fourgous a été désigné
et il l'a emporté ce soir vous êtes
satisfait d'avoir obtenu on va dire gain
de cause mais en tout cas c'était
presque entendue une primaire
l'organisation d'une primaire c'était
important
c'était important qu'ils aient une
primaire pour la clarté du débat pour
qu'on puisse avoir un moment aussi et
que la majorité communautaire qui est
une nouvelle majorité issue des urnes
2014 il ya une alternance et puis aussi
avec les nouveaux entrants qu'on est à
un moment effectivement pour réfléchir à
quel candidat on veut et derrière pour
faire quoi
donc ça s'est passé dans d'extrêmement
bonnes conditions pour tout le monde en
convient et c'était utile et donc
jean-michel fourgous a remporté cette
primaire et il est désormais élus
présents d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines je m'en
félicite je pense que c'était un
candidat tout à fait légitime qui
connaît très bien ce territoire qui a
été élu quatre fois mère d'une des
villes de ce territoire là donc je pense
qu'effectivement cette primaire elle a
donné le résultat qui était qui était
qui était souhaitable et aujourd'hui ce
que je souhaite aussi que soit le point
de départ avoir un nouveau travail on
est à mi mandat
par rapport au mandat qui nous a été
confiée il ya encore beaucoup de choses
à faire et donc espérons que maintenant
puisse passer arrêter les sujets une
d'élections internes c'est normal c'est
de calendrier les élections du coup il y
avait beaucoup à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines maintenant il
faut qu'on revienne et qu'on veut avoir
un bilan solide a présenté aux saint
quentinois
est ce que toutes les sensibilités se
sont exprimés et je pense aux
sensibilités de la droite on pourra
parler de l'opposition plus classique et
va à gauche mais est ce qu'au sein de la
droite aujourd'hui vous avez le
sentiment que tout le monde s'est
exprimé
oui ce sentiment que j'ai eu la parole a
été très libre tout le tous les conseils
communautaires de majorité ont
d'ailleurs pris par voter à cette
primaire là donc c'est bien qu'il y
avait une adhésion au système qui était
proposé et puis derrière si vous voulez
une seule dans une intercommunalité et
c'est vrai que nous sommes loin des
sujets de politique nationale et c'est
tant mieux
il peut y avoir des nuances des
sensibilités mais globalement le but
c'est de faire en sorte que ça
fonctionne très bien
le mieux possible dans l'intérêt des
habitants donc dans la main
or était là dessus toujours y avoir des
nuances et c'est pour ça que c'est
important que chacun s'exprime
mais au moment où il s'agira ce père de
voter le budget nous serons tous en
phase sur les grandes orientations qui
sont importantes pour le territoire et
qui ont déjà été engagées depuis 2014
seul le but aujourd'hui c'est tout de
même de permettre cette expression de la
diversité au sein de la majorité pour
moi une majorité ces trois chaussée une
ligne politique elle a été tranchée
monde la primaire elle est confirmée ce
soir par l'élection du nouveau président
de saint quentin en yvelines jean michel
fourgous et l'accepter des nuances
montant de cette ligne là parce qu'on ne
pas toujours être d'accord
et puis c'est une discipline collective
et danser pour ça que c'est important
qu'ils primaire et qu'ensuite
naturellement le résultat soit confirmée
et nous avons eu ce soir une prise de
parole du maire de trappes du nu maire
de magny les hameaux donc de
l'opposition communautaire qui était
d'ailleurs dans un souci si j'ai bien
compris de faire en sorte que tout ça
fonctionne manière intelligente ils ont
leur légitimité locale je vois même un
élu d'opposition à trappes et donc il
faut à la fois ne pas renier nos
convictions pour qu'on puisse avancer et
en même temps travailler intelligemment
avec tous ceux qui le souhaitent mais il
faut travailler aussi avec d'autres
structures je vous pose la question
parce que vous êtes aussi conseiller
régional ou siéger à la région ile de
france
il ya un travail à ce partenariat qu'il
faut qu'il faut maintenir et avancer
ensemble et on évoquait tout à l'heure
juste avant vous avec jean michel
fourgous ou joséphine coleman berger ce
dossier de la ligne 18 par exemple il ya
une mobilisation commune à avoir avec la
région aussi oui c'est un sujet tout à
fait majeur il faut que l'on par tous
d'une seule voix et c'est le cas
aujourd'hui on est pleinement mobilisé
la présidente de la région valérie
pécresse a sollicité le gouvernement
pour qu'il prenne un engagement ferme
sur un calendrier pour la ligne 18 parce
qu'on ne peut pas jouer sur des sujets
aussi importants derrière celle de le
développement du campus scientifique de
saclay c'est les mobilités du futur à
satory et c'est pour ça quand on y vit
un sujet absolument majeur en
particulier dans la perspective des jeux
olympiques la réalité surtout ses grands
chantiers là c'est nous travaillons déjà
main dans la main de manière très
constructive avec l'exécutif
communautaire tel qu'il existe depuis
2014 donc je suis convaincu que ce
travail va se poursuivre et s'amplifier
vais prendre un exemple le nouveau pôle
de l'innovation de l'entrepreneur et
saint quentin en yvelines qui s'appelle
le ski cupide une très belle réalisation
qui a été voulu par jean michel fourgous
et par michel logis président à l'époque
de saint quentin en yvelines
eh bien ça a été aussi financé par la
région donc la région il vient en appui
nous sommes là compte notre conviction à
la région c'est que saint quentin en
yvelines doit être un pôle économique
majeur en particulier des innovations il
est déjà en termes de poids économique
il faut qu'ils continuent à tirer avec
lui l'ensemble de la région ile de
france
l'avenir de saint quentin en yvelines
vous le voyez comment d'ici la fin de la
mandature un élargissement un
rayonnement économique
ça fait par un élargissement fait partie
du sud on doit encore débattre même si
nous avons atteint une taille
aujourd'hui avec l'entrée de cinq
nouvelles communes tout à fait
convenable est qui et qui à la bonne
échelle mais pendant bas on peut en
parler ce débat-là n'a pas eu lutte qui
vont au sein de la majorité il faudra
qu'il ait lieu si la vocation à l'être
nous verrons c'est ce que souhaite faire
le gouvernement en la matière et il
préfet du département
mais l'arrêté ce que je vois ce qu'il ya
un certain nombre de défis qui ne sont
pas encore relevé c'est normal nous
avons encore des territoires qui sont
fragmentés y compris à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines je suis moi
même élu d'une ville qui connaît un
certain nombre de difficultés sur
laquelle il faut qu'on arrive à l'ancré
dans la même dynamique économique est
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le cas je pense
à trappes mais on pourrait dire la même
chose de la verrière donc sur tous ces
sujets là il ya beaucoup de choses qui
sont faites faudra aller beaucoup plus
loin c'est vraiment un sujet sur lequel
à titre personnel je souhaite qu'on
avance mais je sais que jean michel
fourgous qui est aussi attentif
merci beaucoup aux cammazes au conseil
communautaire donc de saint quentin en
yvelines on referme 7,8 politique un peu
particulier ce mois ci puisque consacrée
à l'élection de ce nouveau président on
se retrouve très vite bien sûr sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le